today history was made when the Speaker
of the House Kevin McCarthy was removed
after Matt Gates filed a motion to
vacate there were what was it 11
defectors Republicans who I shouldn't
call them defectors who who joined with
Democrats and said Kevin McCarthy no
confidence you are no longer speaker we
have more breaking news Kevin McCarthy
will not seek the speakership again
where we go from here I don't know but I
will make it very simple for you in my
opinion obstru and stagnation in
Congress is better than the Republican
leadership teaming up with Democrats in
defiance of the slim majority that was
hardfought in 2022 what's the point of
Republicans having won the majority if
they're not going to exercise their
power over the budget and in fact Kevin
McCarthy would work secret back room
deals with Democrats to fund war and
potentially bring us to World War II